you know her as the iconic Dr Izzy
Stevens on Gray's Anatomy and as the
2000s Queen of the rom-com scene let's
be real 27 Dresses is one of my all-time
favorite guilty pleasure movies because
who doesn't love a good wedding theme
flick but now a mother of three and the
star of the hit show Firefly Lane
Catherine sat down with Harvest Bazaar
to share everything that she eats in a
day and your girl is hungry so let's
dive in hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
we'll be taking a look at everything
Katherine Heigl eats in a day
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including my general trigger
warning we'll be looking at another
person's alleged diet so feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are not
already subscribed here please help a
girl out hit that subscribe and follow
me on Tick Tock and Instagram at Abby's
kitchen alright lovelies let's get in so
start with my coffee in my keeping room
that has my little fireplace in it three
out of eight of my dogs sometimes I do
this really cool little Journal thing
and then a mantra for the day sometimes
I pull my tarot cards because I'm kind
of witchy like that and I really like
witchy stuff I always call my mother
every day twice a day I'm sorry three
kids and eight dogs
I am impressed I mean I am overwhelmed
with two and one so you go girl like
talk about a superwoman hats off to you
now obviously we love a morning routine
no matter what it looks like spontaneous
chaotic Zen witchy whatever the point is
that it should work for you and your
needs and set the tone for the day and
it sounds like Catherine's morning
routine has the works we got fireplaces
an abundance of dogs tarot cards
journaling mantras and coffee chats with
Mom I mean I don't know how she does it
but I am taking notes typically do not
eat until 11ish and I'm really enjoying
Frosted Mini Wheats I love them so much
and I can't stop eating them and
everybody gets mad at me because they
think I need to eat something more
well-rounded or healthy or has protein
or whatever but I'm telling you they
really work for me first of all I love
mini weeds growing up they were one of
our go-to breakfasts we like them
because they had a coating of frosting
on them and my mom liked them probably
because they had the word wheat in them
and she assumed that made them healthy
and as her grown adult dietitian
daughter I gave Grandma sharp a very
enthusiastic thumbs up is you doing a
good job doing a good job one
serving of cereal has about five grams
of protein and six grams of fiber and if
we're serving with regular dairy or soy
or pea milk that would boost the protein
up to 11 grams it's still a light
breakfast and we do know that getting a
good amount of protein in the morning
has a ton of important benefits it
supports muscle mass energy expenditure
nighttime sleep satiety hormones glucose
regulation and more so if we wanted a
more substantial higher protein
breakfast she could do like a basic
Greek yogurt add the Mini Wheats on top
and then throw in a bunch of berries and
like a little drizzle of peanut butter
that actually sounds like really damn
good to me but of course if you prefer a
light breakfast and that feels good to
you amazing live your life girl oh and I
use lactate which I'm also really
enjoying because I have not been able to
drink milk since I was like 14. so
lactate is one of the two most
evidence-based digestive enzymes on the
market the other of which is be known
now I get the digestive enzymes are kind
of hot and trendy these days with every
influencer Under the Sun trying to
convince you that you need one to cure
your bloating but a lot of the influence
are backed digestive enzymes on the
market are not evidence-based or may
only be evidence-based for a small
subsection of the population who have
clinical diagnosed deficiencies not for
every 20-something year old on Tick Tock
ultimately you should also work with a
registered dietitian to help determine
the root cause of your symptoms first
and determine if digestive enzymes would
even be a good fit but if lactose
intolerance is an issue then a lactate
enzyme can definitely do wonders
especially if you don't want to forego
that extra cheesy pizza on date night my
Dairy issues are confusing because I
can't just drink milk but I can have
like half and half or cream can't eat
ice cream but I can eat cheese so yeah
it might seem random but yeah this
actually checks out so a lot of lactose
intolerant folks may find that they can
tolerate certain dairy products like
cheese and yogurt just fine whereas
other dairy products like milk or ice
cream May trigger uncomfortable
digestive symptoms and this is because
yogurt and some cheeses contain
lactobacillus bacteria which can
naturally convert lactose into lactic
acid thereby lowering the amount of
lactose it contains softer cheeses do
tend to have more lactose than like
harder cheeses which are generally aged
longer as for cream or half and half it
has a much higher percentage of its
total volume made up of fat compared to
fluid milk which ultimately leaves less
volume per ounce for lactose which is
the carbohydrate in Dairy skim milk on
the other hand would have no fat so it
contains more lactose per
ounce all that said lactose is a FODMAP
and we all have our own uniquely sized
FODMAP bucket some people's bucket feels
really super quickly and easily and
others can tolerate a lot more so if
you're unsure of your own tolerance
start slow and work your way up so Josh
is our big breakfast maker and he's an
excellent breakfast maker so I just let
him do that like eggs over medium which
I really love and bacon I can't have
eggs without bacon I think that's weird
I do love a good egg scramble like just
cheese tomatoes eggs Tabasco yes want to
know what's better than eggs for
breakfast when someone else makes you
eggs for breakfast husbands take note
I'll I'll be looking for the email I'm
also glad to hear that we have a little
more breakfast variety going on outside
of just Frosted Mini Wheats and if
protein was the concern then eggs are
certainly a super great option as two
eggs provide around 12 grams of protein
and adding some bacon and cheese in
there will bump that up even more oh but
dietitian tip here will be to combine
the eggs with the Mini Wheats so that we
have protein fat and fiber all in one
meal so I live in the middle of nowhere
and I can't order anything in I can't
like run to a smoothie bar and get a
smoothie I have to make the smoothie I
can't get like a pasta salad or a
hamburger and I have to make it and then
I have to clean it up and put it all
away so you get to a point and if the
kids aren't home and they're at school
you're just kind of like I don't want to
bother so I might have another bowl of
rusted mini wheat if this is not a
perfect example of mom life I don't know
what is and totally understandable
considering the whole three kid eight
dog situation like many weeks would be
all I ever eat so no judgment here girl
he makes the best sandwiches he goes all
out I'm the kind of person who's like
all right just throw me some bread some
bologna some cheese some mustard tomato
it's fine he does like the lettuce the
Tomato the sliced onion makes an aioli
at times like takes a lot of pride in it
again husbands take note we don't need
diamond or flowers we need sandwiches
okay but diamonds are also nice shine
bright like a diamond okay but the
homemade aioli like this family of 13
clearly has a different set of hours in
the day because I have not made aioli
since culinary school long before I had
a single dog or child I want this life
we go to this great Italian restaurant
in Park City called bartolo's simple but
really good homemade pasta great salads
like the Serrata and beet salad that I
crave quick simple delicious lunch I
also love sushi there is nothing better
than like a mother-daughter pasta slash
Sushi date and this sounds totally
Divine I also love the way that
Catherine describes food so she uses
words like simple delicious and
frequently points out how much she loves
certain foods you can tell that she eats
food for pleasure and convenience and
doesn't fuss about calories or trendy
superfoods like Mo celebs which is
really refreshing to see also burrata is
definitely up there on my favorite food
list I go through my phases of being
really kind of a health nut and really
going for I did a whole plant-based
thing for a while but I haven't found a
way to really sustain that instead I've
kind of moved more towards just
embracing Whole Foods and just kind of
well-rounded meals and maybe trying to
eat a little less of it if I want to
drop a few okay so I'm glad that
Catherine has found a way of eating that
sustainable and works for her which is
ultimately what any lifestyle change
comes down to all too often we get fed
these kind of quick fixes and fads that
are typically too difficult to actually
maintain over time either because
they're too strict restrictive
unrealistic or all of the above and I
think that aiming to eat more Whole
Foods in a balanced way is a very
sustainable and manageable goal and
dinner is typically my terrain like now
at this time of year for us we're doing
a lot of crock pot chilies a lot of
stews oh we have an air fryer we do a
lot of salmon in the air fryer I'm
really a big fan of the pressure cooker
I do a pumpkin turkey chili other
favorite and super family favorite is
spaghetti bolognese oh and Meatloaf I
have my mother's meatloaf recipe I love
chicken Tiki Masala amazing options and
I'm loving the variety here so we've got
lots of family favorites some cooking
hacks along with some different cultural
flavors I also think that crock pots or
pressure cookers or air fryers are all
great tools for busy parents just trying
to feed themselves and their kids and
they've definitely saved my life more
times than I can count I never used to
be much of a sweets person but now every
night after dinner I have to have a fat
boy do they sell those here is that just
a Utah thing and then some of my
favorite nights though are just a cheese
plate like a charcuterie I love nice
cheese too I love really stinky cheese
like the kind of cheese that you open
your fridge and you're like my God like
a peppered salami or kind of breeze so I
had to Google this fat boy ice cream
situation because it's definitely not
available in Canada trust me your girl
knows all her ice cream options up North
but hello definitely see the Allure ice
cream sandwiches are my jam as are
basically any and all Frozen ice cream
desserts I love that despite her lactose
intolerance it doesn't seem to stop
Catherine from enjoying her favorite
foods which is is a lot of dairy
apparently so if that lactate is working
its magic then I say keep the ice cream
and cheese plates a common not to
mention I actually think cheese and
charcuterie is a really great balanced
bedtime snack we got protein fat and
some fiber rich carbs in any fruit
crackers or bread and with a glass of
wine I mean that's my kind of night that
said there is an old wives tale that
eating cheese before bed will give you
nightmares which can actually be traced
to the movie A Christmas Carol where
Ebenezer Scrooge blamed his ghostly
sightings on a crumb of cheese might be
an undigested beef
I think we can call that one out as BS
as for cheese and quality of sleep we
don't have a lot of specific good
evidence on this but we do have research
that having cheese before bed actually
helped to support a good night's sleep
and despite the study being sponsored by
the British cheese board it actually
does make sense since cheese contains
more of the Sleep supporting amino acid
tryptophan than turkey does plus it has
calcium and protein which can help to
also support our sleep the best sleep
supporting option is cottage cheese
which is naturally lowest in fat and
highest in protein and if lactose is an
issue you can also find it lactose free
you guys know I'm a huge cottage cheese
fan and as an insomniac this is actually
one of the main reasons why overall I
found this video really refreshing and
relatable like it kind of felt like I
was sitting down with my mom friend and
just like dishing over our favorite
foods and sharing our struggles of
working mom survival Catherine clearly
eats her pleasure and she gravitates
towards the foods that she loves and are
easy for her to prepare for her family
and the rest just kind of all falls into
place and I wholeheartedly believe that
if Simplicity and convenience helps you
get food on the table without undue
stress and suffering it is a huge win
for your health so on that note I hope
you guys like this video if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who or what you'd like
to see me review next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]